Warren people want to know what's the
single best piece of advice you've ever
received I've received in a variety of
forums particular for my father when I
was very young but I mean basically I
think taught me how to live not that I
did it perfectly or anything like that
but I mean he was giving me lessons but
he wasn't doing it by preaching to me he
was doing it by example but basically
well the biggest lesson in a sense I got
is the power of unconditional love I
mean I think there is no power on earth
like unconditional love I think that if
you offer that to your child
I mean you 90 percent of the way home
and maybe days when you don't feel like
it it's not uncritical love that's a
different animal but but to know you
always can come back I mean at it that
is huge in life that takes you a long
long way and I would say that every
parent out there that that can extend
that to their child at a very young age
it's gonna make for a better human thing
thank you so much for watching I hope
you guys enjoyed I'd love to know what
you think of this video what you think
of the single best piece of advice
Warren Buffett's ever received and I'm
also curious to know what's a single
best piece of advice that you've ever
received leave it out in the comments
and I will join the discussion thank you
again for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon